Salut. Aujourd'hui je vais vous apprendre à
ne plus jamais perdre au jeu le plus célèbre
Le Morpion.
Ce qu'y a de bien, c'est qu'il existe
plusieurs techniques pour ça
qui sont faciles à retenir
et que même si quelqu'un d'autre
connait ces techniques
vous pouvez quand même lutter
pour, au moins, faire le match nul.
Et regardez bien
jusqu'au bout de la vidéo
parce que même si vous croyez
connaître le morpion,
il y a des variantes qui sont
vraiment intéressantes.
C'est parti !
Générique !
Qu'est-ce qu'il fait là
le coussin ?
[Musique Générique]
Dans le morpion de base,
autrement appelé le Tic Tac Too,
vous devez aligner
3 symboles identiques.
Donc 3 cercles ou 3 croix.
En tout début de partie,
on détermine aléatoirement
quel est le joueur
qui va commencer.
Et c'est là que tout commence...
Soit vous allez jouer en premier,
soit vous allez jouer en 2ème.
Et on va appliquer une stratégie
qui va faire que vous allez
soit gagner,
soit au moins réussir à créer
un match nul.
Donc, vous ne perdrez jamais !
Vous allez voir,
c'est très simple à comprendre.
Si vous êtes le joueur N°1
le joueur qui commence,
alors commencez toujours
par jouer dans un angle.
peu importe la réponse
de l'autre joueur,
où est-ce qu'il mettra
son cercle...
Vous allez jouer votre 2ème coup
sur la même ligne.
En faisant ça et en jouant
normalement derrière,
vous allez créer une situation
où à un moment donné
vous allez avoir 2 possibilités
de gagner
alors que votre adversaire ne peut
contrer qu'une seule possibilité.
donc vous aurez gagné !
Il n'y a qu'un seul cas où
ça ne fonctionnera pas,
c'est quand l'adversaire met son
premier coup au centre.
Dans ces cas là, vous appliquez
la même méthode
vous continuez la même ligne
puis vous jouez normalement
jusqu'au bout.
Et vous allez créer
un match nul.
Maintenant, 2ème cas de figure,
c'est l'adversaire qui commence.
Donc vous allez être
le joueur N°2.
Il y a 3 possibilités :
Soit il commence dans un coin.
Auquel cas, vous, vous jouez
au centre.
Puis vous jouez normalement
et vous allez créer
un match nul.
Soit lui a commencé
au centre
et dans ce cas là vous,
vous vous mettez dans un coin
et vous allez créer aussi
un match nul
en continuant de bloquer votre
adversaire à chaque coup.
Et la 3ème possibilité c'est
s'il commence, lui, sur un bord.
Dans ce cas là, vous,
vous mettez votre premier
coup au centre
Et c'est le seul cas où,
en commençant 2ème,
vous avez une possibilité de gagner.
Après il y a un autre cas,
c'est si l'adversaire fait une erreur.
En mémorisant ça, vous ne perdrez
plus jamais au morpion.
Les seules choses à retenir,
c'est que si vous êtes le 1
vous commencez dans un angle
et vous continuez la ligne.
Si vous êtes le 2,
vous commencez au centre,
puis vous bloquez.
Et s'il a commencé au centre,
vous jouez dans un coin
et vous bloquez.
La tactique est aussi
simple que ça.
Et du coup, le jeu est
aussi simple que ça.
C'est pour ça qu'il existe
des variations
qui sont extrêmement intéressantes.
La première variation c'est
le mental Tic-Tac-Too.
C'est le même jeu,
la même chose,
mais on le joue mentalement.
Il n'y a pas de support papier.
Alors, au départ, les joueurs
doivent se mettre d'accord
sur une numérotation.
Par exemple : les colonnes,
de la gauche vers la droite
sont A, B, C.
Et les lignes, de haut en bas,
sont 1,2,3.
Ce qui fait que le premier joueur
dit, par exemple,
" Je vais placer mon premier
en B2 "
C'est une manière de jouer
qui est très sympa
parce que, déjà, elle est
plus compliquée,
elle autorise l'erreur
des joueurs...
C'es plus "compliqué" de voir
tout ce qui se passe en même temps.
Et, en plus de ça, ça fait travailler
votre visualisation interne.
Personnellement, je n'y joue
que comme ça
et j'aime bien parce qu'on n'a
pas besoin de papier ou de crayon.
Une autre manière d'y jouer
c'est de jouer au Gomoku
Alors je dis GO-MO-KOU
peut-être que ça se dit
GO-MO-CU...
Mais ça sonne tout de suite
différemment...
Le Gomoku, ça se joue avec un tableau
de 19 lignes sur 19 colonnes.
Et on ne va jouer que
sur les intersections,
comme dans le jeu de GO.
D'ailleurs, 19 sur 19,
c'est le jeu de GO.
Ce qui nous fait un total,
je suis persuadé que vous
l'aviez déjà compté
de 361 intersections.
Alors, on y joue avec des pions
en général, si on utilise le jeu de GO
on a les pions blancs et noirs.
Et on ne donne pas 180 pions à chacun,
On donne juste 60 pions
à chacun.
Ça se joue comme au morpion
normal, je vous le dis,
sauf qu'on joue sur les intersections
et le premier qui arrive à faire
5 pions d'affilée
en ligne, en colonne
ou en diagonale,
remporte la partie.
Et on n'est pas obligé
de faire 19 lignes sur 19 lignes.
On peut faire 15 sur 15
par exemple.
C'est sûrement la manière
la plus intéressante de jouer au morpion.
Et après, si vous êtes des tueurs
vous pouvez essayer de jouer à
cette version là, mentalement
personnellement,
je n'ai jamais essayé !
Je vous avais promis qu'on ferait
cette vidéo bientôt.
Ben voilà, ça, c'est fait.
La prochaine vidéo va porter
sur la solution de l'énigme !!
Je vous le dis, j'ai déjà les 100 personnes.
J'ai déjà les 100 gagnants
qui vont participer au tirage au sort.
Mais après, vous pouvez toujours
la résoudre pour vous
Le vrai challenge d'une énigme,
ce n'est pas le gain.
C'est le plaisir de réussir
à la résoudre.
J'essaierai de sortir cette vidéo
en fin de semaine
puisque demain je repars
en tournée.
Je vais être à Rouen durant 3 jours.
Je vous rappelle rapidement
qu'il ne reste que 6 dates de tournée.
Également dans quelques jours
la sortie de mon livre que vous pouvez
déjà pré-commander sur
Amazon, la Fnac, ou chez
votre libraire préféré !
Je voulais dire un petit message
aux 467244 abonnés :
Oui ! Ça a encore augmenté
depuis la dernière vidéo, merci.
Vous avez euh... littéralement
détruit la dernière barre de likes
sur la vidéo précédente
par rapport à la story.
Je crois même qu'on va atteindre
l'objectif plus tôt que prévu.
Mais en tout cas, ça a mis la vidéo
dans les tendances
donc merci pour ça.
[Riant] N'hésitez pas. Si vous voulez
vous faire plaisir sur celle-ci...
vous pouvez lâcher un like ; vous abonner.
A très bientôt. Ciao !
[Musique Générique de fin]